sapete ragazzi che non avevo mai provato
a vedere quante cose [ __ ] ci sono nel
menu di sixty seconds ogni cosa che
clicco è una figata tipo questa chiudere
il gioco non ho capito perché ho tolto
la corrente cioè ma sono robe geniali
facciamo una partita che da un po che
non ci giochiamo sono curioso di vedere
che cosa combino esco ora il giorno 13
gol picuti allora ragazze non vinco non
mi colava cinque anni a si sapeva niente
cioè l'unica volta che ho visto è stato
quando celato con pietro come caso è
possibile tutto ciò per adesso tutto
bene giorno 3 primo primo tentativo di
sopravvivenza ragazzi e mandare
ovviamente fuori qualcuno certamente il
padre porterei la valigia vuota così
avvenuti porti un pochino valente di
portare un po di roma
avete capito no io prenderei il corso la
mappa ok è la maschera certo che sono
concas la maschera per forza el ho
fucile però non sai che forse mi porto
lascia che è meglio non ho mai capito se
effettivamente questa cosa ragazzi non
ha mai capito se la valigia deve uscire
vuota così almeno portiamo roba oppure
se conviene portare piu europa fuori non
l'ho mai capito cosa vedi sempre hayden
acqua a everybody ed erika c'è una
persona che ci manca l'avere nostro
prezioso terry
ah non lo so lo zio terry trattasse
persone strepitose tuttavia non erano
soprattutto ricordi usiamo il corso da
boy scout certo cosa a me frega lo zio
terni guardiamo che cos'è la boy scout
non vedo perché no non vedo perché no
le amo certi la fodera tre pagine
manuale scarpe magari sono proprio utile
questo è sicuro non hanno più sete
avranno fame tra qualche giorno qua
sotto c'è è facile perde la cognizione
del tempo ma io ci ha ricordato che oggi
i capelli timi
non lo so che lo usiamo la dama tenevano
la scassi
bravo timi giocata ma nessuno sa fa la
radio non emetto solo da ora abbiamo
bisogno di notizie vai kamoun accenni st
radio e facciamo si che arrivi qualcuno
a salvarci che siamo al giorno sette già
stiamo per morire per allora quello c'è
una foto aspetta ma stato quasi sempre
stata allo zio terre e il prozio derry
sarà lui che una volta fare ragazzi io
direi di dare di aspettare ancora
giovane poi dà da mangiare bere a tutti
durante la notte abbiamo sentito rumori
sospetti provenire da dietro la porta
una valigia in pelle let's go spero che
siete il gattone scenico d'arma strano
però al giorno 8 shari top sarà lui no
non è lo scià ricco perché cazzate una
zuppa qualcuno ci ha dato una zuppa al
pomodoro va bene fame set telescope
buono e due perfette timineri genoa
bisogno di esercizio fisico fare allora
quelle fuori landa desolata sembra po
azzardata ma potrebbe invece giocare nel
rifugio l'acchiappa rella perché non
provare il no che spaccano tutto per
favore non fate esercizio mai fare
palestra nei bunker parco lemonia poi
tutti sudati dove vi lavate che schifo
state fermi c'è un apocalisse corsa
esatto ogni volta che mi chiedono di
fare palestra rispondono così ma il
padre non è tornato più c'è partito il
primo giorno è morto cioè portato un
sacco di roba spero più una scatola più
un'acqua più lo spray e basta cioè che
merda ma possibile ma come e sarebbe
figo andare lei me rigenerata nella
landa desolata visto che è l'unica che
ci può andare in questo momento parola
no effettivamente capito perché dopo
tutto sto casino il padre ha trovato due
robe c'è una merda
hai fatto cagare sua spedizione dovremo
andare a parigi con la valigia vuota che
non ha senso
io direi che si meritano di mangiare
libere tutti
credono fare così sembra la cosa più
giusta
mary jane take this valigia elevati dei
[ __ ] vediamo cosa succede ragazzi
doveva fare ciò che l'interesse moratti
mi va bene speriamo si faccia tirare su
il morale anche se dubito mary j quanta
lo avrei portato
la zia ha portato il botto l'acqua vero
ma le valigie ok più 2 acqua più una
zuppa più pan bagnato abbiamo anche il
kit per fa rinsavire la mamma non male
non male non male
dolores potrebbe sopravvivere
io direi di curare timi e mandare
dolores fuori a sto punto vai un'attenta
e abbastanza allora niente mandiamo
tende di nuovo perché ha fatto cagare
però la prossima volta parla di meglio
ma per i team in valigia solo questa ti
levi dalle palle ed madonna non spero
veramente che l'hotel ha fatto veramente
schifo spero che faccia qualcosa di
decente magistra volendo di fare meglio
dare cosa mangiare da oggi altrimenti
non ti do niente è solo pazza e la
medicina ha sempre fame
ai ragazzi e [ __ ] mary jane è
stata sorpresa a sgattaiolare via nel
cuore della notte
ma che cazzo fai zia ma scusa dolores si
è infuriata quando ha scoperto che aveva
un appuntamento con un giovane bandito
sembra che lo abbia incontrato durante
la spedizione me diceva che se i poteri
almeno far avere un biglietto di scuse
per non essersi presentata che sia una
buona idea certo mandato a sto punto
cazzola ha rapito mary jane sicuro
no è tornata pazza va bene un carro
armato in fondo alla via è sprovvisto di
ruote ma è rinforzato con griglie di
metallo ma le armi questo pericolo ha
bisogno di nardò scivola fuori
equipaggiati e cerchiamo che cosa ti ha
datto
lucchetto reazione
che che gara ma è un lucchetto e lo
spiega perché dovrei andare dall avv
perché hai portato un lucchetto in un
carro armato non ho capito che estenda
la cassa fonde la cassaforte di un
bandito dentro c'erano degli yo yo è una
mitragliatrice pesante abbiamo chiuso la
cassaforte con lucchetto così non
potremo più aprirla va bene ma c'erano
tutti sempre fame ragalma possibile ma
possibile mai
donna dolore sono vedere un gas che
tanto deve uscire magni fuori ai ragazzi
finchè non torna dolores sono cazzi fa
anche rima sta roba effettivamente però
non
ci serve un kit medico devo curare
curare il padre almeno perché sennò sono
kaki ted devi essere curato porco
demonio fame disidratazione va bene
ragazzi finite cio non sei provviste
credi è tornato qualcuno dovrà restare
giornata c'è un sacco di roba aspetta
quattro bottiglie
lo abbiamo preso quattro bottiglie nei
bambini va bene ok dolore si è portato
due zucchi un lucchetto
manca solo make it sono eccome e con
solo come con siamo partiti praticamente
ottimo non male raga non mai veramente
no è morto timi cacchio e niente
mandiamo ted ma che cazzo aveva aveva la
valigia la mappa il fuci tutto aveva
team mi dispiace più per la roma che ha
perso che pertini stesso meligeni
scappata perché dava da mangiare
ma dai
siamo rimasti due gol uno è morto
l'altro è scappata operai che va va va
va a the ok va bene
dai ted camon tutto quello che non
abbiamo di riportare a lei niente ma vai
vai e vivi cerca di vivere io mi prendo
cura di dolores
cinquantatreesimo giorno speriamo
insomma ragazzi comunque impossibile far
sopravvivere tutti è già il più
impossibile vincere veloci con sopra via
la gente è assurdo il suo gioco
proviamo a vedere che c'è su no
o sono morti sono lì che succede no il
nostro rifugio è stato invaso da una
panda di sforzi e volgari malviventi lo
squadron i loro occhi non prometteva
nulla di buono se avessimo resistito
solo notch hanno sparato ma a casa ma no
non ci credo ma non sparate i malviventi
ma dai ma dai perderà ancora fuori
poteva ancora tornata che ne so io però
ci siamo certo ragazzi e mi piace anche
per i soci ha guidato nella stazione
centrale si chiede non ci vediamo come
sempre alla prossima vino e ragazzi
[Musica]